okay bye my talk it's now 11:30 Oh stow
that forget the next couple of talks
under way the first will be given by
Igor Oliveira okay thanks this is joint
work with Rahul and my plan for this
talk is to give you a sort of high level
overview of this notion of harness
magnification and I am gonna be focusing
on the main conceptual points okay so a
lot of research in recent years has gone
into understanding connections between
the design of non-trivial
algorithms improving superpolynomial
lower bounds and we have now pretty
decent understanding of disconnections
in settings such as satisfiability
randomization learning the topic of this
talk is a bit dual to this approach for
lower bounds the game here is to extract
from barely non-trivial lower bound
probes superpolynomial lower bounds okay
so in some sense this to approach are
due to each other so here is the idea we
know that strong lower bounds are very
hard to combine and on the other hand we
have weak lower bounds in many
computational models such as formulas so
magnification theorem is a theorem
showing the following is starting from a
very weak lower bound that is just
barely super linear we will extract from
this proof super polynomial lower bound
from an explicit function so during this
talk whenever I say super linear you
should really think of n to the 1 plus
Epsilon just to simplify the
presentation and this is an interesting
approach because as I'm going to explain
shortly it seems to avoid a natural
poof's barrier
so remember the natural proofs sort of
partitions the set of circuit classes
into two worlds on the one hand we have
the circuit classes that can compute
pseudo-random functions and for such
classes we have no lower bounds or the
applied week and there are the week
classes where we have a variety of
techniques many of them combinatorial
and for which we can prove pretty strong
lower bounds and natural proofs sort of
says that whenever pseudo-random
functions are in that class we shouldn't
hope to prove lower bounds using
constructive techniques so we would like
to avoid natural proofs and to have new
techniques to prove lower bounds against
wrong models of computations so just to
recall the definition of natural
property so that's an algorithm that is
the runs in polynomial time in a certain
input length it accepts most of the
input strings but it rejects every
string that has a short description or
it's computable by small circuit and by
result of Ryan from a few years ago and
I think Ryan will be covering this
result in his class during the semester
so roughly speaking he proved that if
you wanna shoulder bounds against an X
then inevitably you're gonna obtain a
property that is at the same time
constructive and useful so if you want
to avoid natural proofs you should go
for a violation of the largeness
condition now how does harness
magnification seem to avoid largeness
condition the point is that as I'm going
to explain the magnification approach it
applies to very specific problems so
from the barely super linear lower bound
for a function f we're gonna get a super
polynomial lower bound for a function H
that is very dependent on F and it's not
clear at all how we would extract from
just the super linear lower bound for F
superpolynomial lower bound for almost
all function
so the argument is very specific to some
function that depends on it okay so this
is sort of like the heuristic argument
for why magnification is good in the
sense of natural properties and now let
me tell you a bit about what has been
said in this direction of magnification
sometimes is in different names but the
results are out they have the same
spirit so to my understanding the first
field that is stated in this language of
magnification is this one by signifies
in front mm so he looks at the click
problem on undirected graphs so the
input length is anxious to M and he
considers the problem of approximating
the size of the largest clique in the
graph but for a huge approximation
factor okay so it's almost linear in the
number of input vertices and he proved
the following if one can show a super
linear lower bound on the complexity of
this problem for randomized algorithms
did you get that NP is not contained in
VPP so at least for this very specific
problem super linear lower bound implies
a super polymer lower bound for another
explicit problem but one of the goals of
this harness magnification a line of
work at least to me is to make this
theorems as close as possible to
settings where we can show lower bounds
and perhaps get new unconditional or
bounds using magnification so this is a
problem that seems to be very hard to
analyze so you need to prove our bounds
against huge approximation factors for
clique and also in a model for which you
don't we didn't understand some like
that several different results in this
paper he has results for uniform and
non-uniform now a much more well-known
result in this area is this one by Erik
and Hal from 2008 and they show a way to
separate NC 1 from this is 0 and the
theorem is the following so there are
some insulin complete language
that if you can show a super lineal
rebound against this is zero circuits
for this language and you get at NC one
is not contained in TC 0 and follow-up
work of leapt on your millions they
prove the similar statement with respect
to size depth lower bounds and for a
function in polynomial time
okay so these are very interesting
results because they tell us something
about hardness of proving superlinear
bounces and models but if you want to
use these theorems to actually get new
lower bounds you're in trouble because
for instance if you look at the Alina
car theorem you need to prove super-lean
the lower bounds for this is zero for
some very specific functions and we
don't have this lower bounds even if you
go all the way up to n here okay and
similarly I'm not aware of any kind of
size depth read offs or a function u P
so an interesting question here is can
we prove such magnification theorems in
settings where we do have lower bounds
and very interestingly a result along
these lines was established last year in
the setting of proof complexity so here
is a film by moritz mueller in the NP
now I'm talking about proof complexity
only in this slide so they show that
there are some specific topologies of
size m and if this tautologies require
bounded depth Fraga proofs of almost
linear like super linear size then we
can get super polynomial size lower
bounds of Fraga systems which is like a
major of a problem in probe complexity
so the interesting aspects of this
result at the phonee
first lower bounds for bernadette frag
are known by work of aitai and many
other people and at the same time the
specific tautology that they employ in
this theorem
they were investigated before this work
they're just truth tables autologous
including the hardness of some boolean
functions and work of raspberr all for
instance has proved that such tautology
they don't have short troops in risk a
certain balance of K so we don't have a
magnification theorem in a setting where
we can prove lower bounds not yet for
the specific pathologist's but that
seems to be progress with respect to the
previous theorems I mentioned before and
what we ask now is can we prove similar
magnification theorems in the
of circle complex because often circuit
complexed is easier to understand
improve complexity yes so it would seem
like from what you're describing the
technologies that if you actually prove
the technologies you get a circuit lower
bound or at least like this would give
you the heat kind of uniform proof of
the technologies would give you this is
saying like a super linear lower bound
on the proof length implies the super
amount of all of these pathologies would
that be a useful property it depends on
also the notion of uniformity plays a
role in this connections between natural
proofs and lower bounds let me take it
offline okay so now let me tell you
about some new results in the setting of
circuit complexity and in some scenarios
where we do have lower bounds so these
are new magnification freedoms they seem
to be closer to the lower bounds we
currently have in place so our results
they like they give a few examples of
magnifications of magnification theorems
and crucially these results are in
settings where we do have unconditional
lower bounds and in this work we don't
know yet how to prove lower bounds for
the problems where we have magnification
but we will observe that there are
closer to related lower bounds for other
problems okay so in this talk I'm gonna
be covering magnification for variance
of mcsp graph problem and 3sat
okay in which case I'm gonna define a
problem Q and just a very weak lower
bound for cubes a stronger Brown for
some explicit problem and this is a
sound type approach to lower bounds
because if you make standard assumptions
this week lower bounds they should hold
actually much stronger lower bounds from
true and this week lower bounds they
really just barely non-trivial okay so
let's start with the simplest example
the K vertex cover problem
so given this undirected graph using the
adjacency matrix representation so the
input lamp is M and we're going to
understand if that is a vertex cover of
size K so our first theorem is
magnification from AC zero lower bounds
so remember H zero is an extremely weak
module cannot even compute the parrot
function and we show the following let K
be log into the C where C is a large
constant that we can pick if for every
depth D there exists an epsilon such
that K vertex cover cannot be computed
by almost linear size circuits of that D
then NP requires super polynomial size
formulas so you can reduce the NP versus
nc1 problem to the investigation of the
complexed of this graph problem with
respect to e zero series of almost
linear size
and for this choice of parameters K log
n to the C if you are some ETH then the
complexity of the problem should be
exponential in omega of K for this
choice of K this is gonna be super fun
it is the input length anxious to the
jaysis matrix representation for the
problem in any questions about this
statement
you can pick C large enough and then you
show a lower bound for that fix it C
against a scissor service
okay so now let me move to the second
example of magnification you have
already seen the minimum circuit size
problem now we're going to be using an
average case variant of the problem so
this is this is about the definition of
the problem I'm gonna be talking about
worst case story bouncing aeternam so
here now we have two additional
parameters alpha and beta and the yes
inputs are the truth truth tables that
can be alpha approximated by circuits of
sight at most yes so f is just a
fraction of inputs where the circuit
gets correctly now the no inputs are the
functions that cannot be beta
approximated by circuits of sizes now
result alpha is actually going to be one
so yes instances are just functions with
small circuits but we're gonna be using
a small gap for the no instances so
these will be the functions that cannot
be let's say 0.99 approximated by
circuits of sizes this is gonna be a
promise problem because you have these
functions between alpha and beta but but
when I say average case it's just the
notion of complex for the strings when I
define the problem so this is worst case
promise problem or theorem here is the
following let's pick the size parameter
for mcsp to be to the little of N and
let's pick the average case harness
parameter to be 1 minus Delta where
Delta is exponentially small okay so
this is almost mcsp accepted the no
instances they cannot be lets say 0.99
approximated by a small circle now if
this problem cannot be computed by
formulas of super linear size if the
required forms of super linear size then
NP is not in NC 1 so this is an example
of magnification from very small formal
lower bounds and how it implies NP is
not in insulin
the harness certificate here for the
problem is that even this version of
mcsp clearly defines a natural property
so if you believe cliffs Ark is secure
then this problem should be much much
harder than just for almost linear size
formulas
okay so now let me tell you about some
closely related lower bounds for this
problem so here's the set of instances
we have the easy functions that can be
exactly computed by circles of size s
and here is a set of negative instances
there's a time gap and the average case
hard with respect to this tiny get so if
you wanna establish any P is not in in
c1 then the parameters for the problem
are s is to the epsilon n where epsilon
goes to 0 and the Delta is exponentially
small as well so we need to show this
doesn't have formulas of size n to
capital n to the 1 plus epsilon Capital
n is the input length for the same CSP
problem and what is known is that if you
look at the standard worst-case version
of mcsp then the problem requires
formulas of almost quadratic size so now
you can't look at this lower bound proof
and try to understand what are the Hart
instance is employed in this lower bound
through right because the set of yes
instances is the same for our problem
for mcsp but we have this tiny gap for
the no instances so the question is are
there no instances using this lower
bound
I also a bit far from the s instances or
not and in terms of the size parameter
this lower bound is pretty good for us
compared to magnification s sub
exponential but if you expect the proof
the lower bound is gonna use a delta
parameter which is actually tiny it's
much less than 2 to the minus 0.99 n
where for magnification we cannot handle
a dowser that is so tiny the message is
that the hard instances produced by this
lower bound it pretty close to the
border of the user functions and that's
the reason why we cannot combine
magnification and this particular lower
bound improved that NP is not an insulin
at least like informally you seem to be
close to it technically
any questions about this discussion yeah
for magnifications enough that epsilon
goes to 0 so this is this is definitely
enough for you it's just the gap here
that's not sufficient can you say that
so is it like an error or is it really
like a worst-case thing you know what I
mean like in the actual event so the no
instance if they if you change some
small number of positions in the truth
table they become easy like you said
it's much smaller can you quantify that
like a little bit more yeah so the Delta
there is less than 2 to the minus 0.99
in and the Delta that we need here
cannot be so small okay the last resort
i wanna mention is a connection between
the 3sat lower bounds and the
randomization so we know that this is
one of the frontier questions in this
area can we separate an X from VPP and
we would like to connect this durand a
musician frontier to proving cippolini
lower bounds for 3sat so this will be
the ideal connection so on the one hand
we have the problem showing like weak
lower bounds for 3sat showing that 3sat
is not in almost linear size almost
linear time algorithms maybe for
Anthony's and on the other hand we would
like to understand if VPP is not large
enough to compute the whole of in X so
the ideal theorem will be something like
if 3sat requires super linear time then
an X is not contained in VPP so somehow
understanding of what happens in the
near linear time regime can tell us
something about polynomial time
computations in general but
unfortunately we don't know yet how to
prove this version of the theorem we can
prove something along these lines if we
use the notion of prefilter so every
future is something a bit stronger than
just showing that 3sat is not in VI
we will actually need to find an
algorithm that produces hard instances
for a candidate 3sat algorithm ok so
this is the formal statement suppose
that for every probabilistic machine
that house that helps in nearly linear
time M here is the bit length
representation of the 3sat instance
suppose for every algorithm running at
this time and using just poly logarithm
many random bits now there exists a
polynomial time deterministic machine so
this is this refute or R and this
machine on infinitely many input lamps M
it gets one to the M and outputs a tree
C&F formula of length M and for
infinitely many values of M this
formulas the witness that a does not is
not correct with high probability over
that instance okay so you witness
infinitely off and formulas where the
algorithm is not correct if high
probability and you are allowed to pick
the refute er after you see the
algorithm so for every opera from you
can design your filter so if that is
possible then an X is different from VPP
ok so this is a stronger requirement
than just saying 3sat is nothing vp time
into the pole into the pole login we
also need this refute comparing to
previous work in its area if you have
the deterministic subtle Griffin then we
know how to build a polynomial time
deterministically filter this is allowed
to run for more time than Masato Griffin
at the same time if you had a randomized
algorithm we can view the randomized
filter so the reason this freedom
doesn't implies doesn't imply a next
visit different from BP is that we need
a deterministic polynomial time refute
ur for randomized algorithms running
almost linear time and we've just poly
buggered from any random bits
any questions about this statement use
it as a witness method and a bunch of
other place
okay so one way you can interpret these
results is that this partition between
weak and strong circuit classes is
somewhat illusory or at the very least
it depends on the problem for which
we're trying to show lower bounds okay
and at least in theory it is sufficient
that we focus on the weak models and get
a much better understanding of this big
models if you want to show lower bounds
against like polynomial size formulas at
the listing fear you can reduce these
problems to a better understanding of
three classes you know I still have a
few minutes I want to tell you about the
general template for some of these
proofs not for all of them but the idea
is quite simple so I have this problem Q
and we're going to show if it doesn't
have let's say linear sized circles then
there's some explicit problem H that is
connected to Q that requires super
polynomial size circuits so the natural
approach here is to argue using the
contrapositive so we're going to assume
that H is easy
so it has circles of size n to the K for
a fix it cake and we're gonna use such
circuits to design an almost linear size
circuit for Q okay and for this to make
sense because this guy here has circles
of size n to the K which is not linear
you want to reduce the instances of Q
through instance of age of sub
polynomial size then you can apply
slightly larger segments okay so the
rule of the game is just somehow try to
compress the inputs of Q into like
smaller pieces and then to use some oxy
lira circle to solve the problem so this
is the general template but the
technical details of course is going to
be very different in each theorem
okay but that's the general idea so now
I just want to tell you about the main
ingredients in some of these proofs so
the first few I mention about the graph
problem K vertex cover and how you can
investigate NP versus NZ 1 by just
proving superlinear aces you don't know
where bounds for this problem what we're
going to be using is some ideas from
parametrized complexity so
how you compressed an instance to much
smaller instance and we also going to be
exploring the power of a c0 to actually
make this entire computation very
efficient that's important understanding
of the class for which is showing the
magnification period and finally you we
can use some simple connections between
c1 and AC zero circuits to make the
connection between get your classes okay
it's not the hard proof now for the
average case version of mcsp we employ
some intuition some ideas from learning
theory and the intuition here is that
somehow if if you take a random
projection of the truth table you still
get information about the answer to the
original patient so this is like you
need to sort of define this new
compressed version of the problem in a
proprietary doing and you also need to
handle randomization here you need to
Duran demise the argument but this is
not so hard here and finally the
connection between 3sat and an X versus
BBP it's a bit more complicated and the
other probes and we need to combine a
few theorems here such as highly
efficient versions of the PCP theorem is
the witness method so they compress the
sixteenth version of Prasad's not so
easy to define need to be done in a very
careful way and to implement this
argument we need also to handle
different notions of time bounded
kamagra of complexity so this is a more
complicated proof
okay so uh let me tell about or I think
are the main problems in this research
line to meet the one of the most
interesting ones is can we use harness
magnification to prove new lower bounds
and I think this isn't like a good
approach to lower bounds because somehow
it combines the power of the class so
upper bounds with lower bounds and our
experience in recent years is that
exploring upper bound this is also
something interesting in connection to a
lot so this seems to be going in the
right direction because of this second
question is are there barriers to
magnification is there like a deeper
reason for why we cannot prove this weak
lower bounds are necessary for a
separations such as NP vs and so on and
finally can we prove a generic hardness
magnification fear and in boolean
complexity so there is no time n ssin
here they hold for like specific
problems but we have more general
theorems in other contexts like this
work of Marco Rizzo and Shahen IVA where
they prove genetic magnification in for
noncommutative romantic sequence I think
it would be extremely interesting is
something like this also holds like in
public
yeah yeah okay now I want to tell you
about some new results that we posted
online this week these theorems
represented in that stock they showed
magnification round around linear size
lower bound a natural question here is
can harness magnification maybe shed
some light into it like existing
frontiers in circuit board bounds for
instance lower bounds or formulas near
the cubic barrier so it's not clear to
me that there is a precise explanation
for this barriers or just frontiers in
terms of magnification but I want to
tell you about a specific example that
is somehow connected to this okay so I
mentioned the magnification theorem for
average case mcsp and this closely
related lower bounds and because we know
how to prove the lower bounds for the
worst case version of mcsp and
understanding the worst case version of
the problem seems to be easier it makes
sense to try to prove magnification
theorems for the standard worst-case
version of the problem right and lycra
who said we have a theorem along these
lines for mcsp but i want to mention
another result which somehow extends to
more general settings instead of just
polynomial size circuits it also works
for like bounded app circuits so if you
change the notion of complex stuff
streams from circuit size to some
variance of time bounded comma Grob
complexity we are able to use like
standard techniques to sort of make the
transition between worst-case and
average case hardness and then we can
prove magnification theorems for
worst-case versions of the problem okay
and the intuition is that this
worst-case versions they should be
easier to analyze and to prove lower
bounds
but as soon as you get these worst-case
versions and the magnification theorems
the magnification thresholds they tend
to appear is slightly above the current
lower bound frontiers in many many
models of computation so for instance
for this problem Q we can show
magnification near the cubic frontier
implying an X was not in insulin and at
the same time we can unconditionally
prove that this problem is not
computable by formulas of near quadratic
size so we can get magnification
freedoms in this new work for worst-case
versions of the problem where we can
analyze this problems and prove lower
bounds for them but the magnification
threshold often goes above normal about
so this happens in many circuit models
it doesn't happen in all of them and
another theorem from this new work is
like rahu explained the first
magnification result for the worst-case
version of mcsp and here there's
something very interesting compared to
the previous freedom that I explained
which is that we really don't know how
to compress mcsp like the worst-case
version of the problem okay it's not
clear if you can reduce an instance of
ram capital and join instance of length
just s so we need to use new ideas here
to prove the magnification figure and
the template is not exactly the one I
presented before for like the general
case and finally and in this work we use
this magnification theorem to point out
what could be a possible new approach to
separate X from nc1 and if you look at
the lower bounds we already have in the
paper if you could extend this lower
bounds for a model where you have just
an extra layer of parity gates at the
bottom that will be sufficient to
separate text from James 1 so just some
sense just like a layer of Pettit's away
from the explosion and so on but it's
not clear to me how hard it is to
understand this little face
this is 0-1 separation so it's actually
a layer of parrots for formulas so you
although you allow the morgan formulas
to compute parrots at the leaves and you
need to prove a super lineal rebound for
this variant of mcsp that talks about
time bounded kamagra of complexity so we
already have formal lower bounds which
are super linear but we don't have
superlinear lower bounds when you also
have the parrot s if you can do there to
get the text with nothing yeah we have
for the different problem you need to
show for disposition yeah so yes this
was just advertising the papers check
you see see see for more details and
question
do you know if you can I think it's a
very good question if you can just
analyze the weak models and get new or
different proofs of existing lower
bounds I haven't worked in that
direction but I think it's a very good
one too
any other questions yes right it's a
MSSP in the usual sense there's a tiny
gap between the years and no instances
so technically yes you need like the
smaller instances to be up sighs let's
see
shoot the little of N and the audience
is like to the little little n times n
there is like a time gap yes yeah so
some sense the kernelization theorems if
you can implement the reductions very
efficiently you can view Dennis
magnification theorems always but we
have examples now of magnification
theorems that don't go in this direction
you actually need to do something else
so yeah and elidio ac0 parents but
vertex cover we apply and dependency one
very guess did this is happy this we
general found on the expertise efficient
there is a happy with these specific
instances so it has to be for this
particular choice of K which is login to
the C versus a large constant so we are
at a very special regime of parameters
where we can do the magnification in
almost linear size is zero and we
believe the problem to be hard so you
need to explore this very small regime
of parameters
any more questions thank you
[Applause]